[موسيقى]
والله لو
رجالكم عندما كنت في ايران كنت اشارك في
الاحتجاجات خاصه في مدينه كم يران كان
النظام الايراني يقتل الكثير من الشعب لم
يرحم احدا للنساء ولا حتى الاطفال الان
انا بامان هنا
امنه الان في هذا الكهف او هكذا تعتقدين
التي ترفض اظهار وجهها لكن قائدها يظن
العكس دير الادواء
بعد الاحتجاجات الاخيره في ايران شنت
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه هجمات عنيفه على
احزاب المعارضه يوجه النظام الايراني بعد
الاتهامات ضد الاحزاب الكرديه يقول النظام
اننا نقود الاحتجاجات في ايران استخدم
النظام الصواريخ والطائرات المسيره
الانتحاريه لقصف الاحزاب الكرديه في 28 من
سبتمبر 2022
لم يكن هذا اوله هجوم الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
ولن يكون الاخير
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نكن وحدنا الحاضرين في هذا المكان على
الغالب فمسيره النظام الايراني تراقب
وترصد تحركاتهم باستمرار فهم اهداف تلجا
ايران لضربها عند الحاجه
[موسيقى]
في هذه الكوفه التي تنتشر في جبل قراداخ
في السليمانيه كردستان العراق يتمركز
ويتحصن عناصر بيش ماركه التابعين لحزب
كومن الايراني المعارض
كل هذا لتفادي ضربات الايرانيه التي تزداد
مؤخرا ومع هذا يبقون اهدافا مكشوفه للنظام
الايراني
يعتمد الجزء الاكبر من هجماتهم على
المراقبه الجويه التي تقوم بها الطائرات
المسيره في بعض الاحيان قبل قصف موقع ما
قد يقومون بالمراقبه الجويه عشرات المرات
الطائرات المسيره مسلحه بكاميرات وتستخدم
لجمع المعلومات الاستخباريه عن الموقع لا
اعتقد ان لديهم معلومات استخباراتيه على
الارض وبدلا من ذلك يعتمدون على الطائرات
المسيره
التدريبات العسكريه جزء من انشطتهم
اليوميه يتشاركوا فيها الشباب والشابات
تبقيهم في حاله جهوزيه والهدف في مرمى
بنادقهم لكن المعركه مؤجله مع النظام
الايراني وهذا ما تشترك فيه كل الاحزاب
الايرانيه المعارضه التي تؤكد انها لن
تبدا المعركه انطلاقا من اراضي كردستان
العراق سار بن عيشوبه العربيه كردستان
العراق